the head of russia's space agency has
thrown more doubt over future
cooperation in the international space
station
the iss is jointly run by the russian
u.s european canadian and japanese space
agencies
russian technology is essential for its
operation
the chief of roskamas says they'll soon
put forward proposals to end cooperation
let's go live now to hashem habada who's
in moscow hashem what do we know
we're basically the head of the
russian space agency los cosmos vitriol
goes in is going to offer those present
those proposals to the government in
russia and see how it goes he didn't
provide any timeline about whether when
those decisions will be made but
at the same time he said that
he got a message from nasa from the
european space agency canadian space
agency talking about the need to
continue cooperation with ross cosmos
when it comes to the international
space
station if you look at the developments
over the last few days you're getting a
sense of the russians trying to
retaliate on different fronts they
started with the
exchange mechanism whereby the assad we
would like to get
paid in rubble when it comes to the
gas
exports to the unfriendly countries and
now they're extending this to the
international space station and this is
really instrumental because the iss
itself has been the very symbol of
partnership between the russians and the
americans after the collapse of the
soviet union the research platform uh
the land of a football field orbiting
some 400 kilometers
above earth is quite instrumental for
the international community for
scientists those looking for research
and exploring the universe and the head
of ross cosmos himself earlier this
month warned that the americans on their
own won't be able to operate the iss
because the russians
are the ones who look after the
navigation and delivering fuels both
countries have also been instrumental in
sharing flights with uh using each other
spacecrafts to towards the international
space station the biggest concern now if
there's no improvement in relations and
the situation remains strained between
those countries we have to see wait and
see what happens if the russians decide
one day to sever ties with with the
americans when it comes to iss i have
also to remind our viewers that that
partnership itself is very crucial
because now the end date for the uh
operations in iss is 2024 and all the
countries have been now working out
details of prolonging the operations in
iss all the way towards 2030. so we have
we have to wait and see what will be the
outcome uh
from those proposals presented by
roscosmos to the government but the
the notion that there is no timeline
here could give us any indication that
we are looking forward to see some
improvement in talks in the near future
or at least guaranteed from the
international community that the west is
going to be
willing to lift the sanctions imposed on
russia
hashma about it there for us in moscow
thank you